ce coup de massue à présent dans le
monde de la gastronomie tout range elle
le restaurant Charles barrier ouvert
depuis 1952 avenue de la tranchée va
définitivement fermer ce samedi il
s'agissait du seul restaurant de la
région à voir obtenu trois étoiles au
guide Michelin c'était en 1968 une
cessation d'activités annoncée sobrement
sur le site internet de l'établissement
qui était pourtant devenu une
institution au fil des années Clémence
dosc et Léa Turquie
c'est affiché partout sur la devanture
de l'établissement le restaurant Charles
barrier ferme ses portes c'est la fin
d'une époque et d'une véritable
institution de la gastronomie Touran
même si le restaurant charbarié n'avait
plus le prestige qu'il avait eu du temps
du vivant de Charles ballet qui fut un
immense cuisinier et moi je garde des
repas avec une cuisine très ciblée sur
des spécialités
les poissons le beurre blanc une cave
prestigieuse avec des anciens millésimes
de Vouvray bien entendu le restaurant a
acquis ces lettres de noblesse grâce au
chef Charles barrier son propriétaire à
partir de 1945 et pendant plus de 50 ans
un travail salué d'un titre de Meilleur
Ouvrier de France et trois étoiles
Michelin jusqu'à son départ en 1996 le
navire change de capitaine la famille
Barier revend le restaurant à l'actuel
propriétaire Jacques Magor et mon père a
porté haut les couleurs de la gas les
amis françaises et celle du Val de Loire
c'est une nouvelle qui qui nous attriste
qui m'attriste et attriste la famille
parce qu'il faudrait aucunement que cet
événement en fait porte atteinte au nom
et à la mémoire de Charles barrier une
fermeture ramenée par une succession de
coups durs entre période covid et graves
problèmes de santé du gérant le
restaurant n'a pas pu maintenir le cap
on est une entreprise mais avant tout on
était comme une famille voilà on a créé
des liens des liens ensemble on a pris
les soins des uns des autres donc c'est
ça qui qui va qui va plus nous manquer
ça va être très difficile de retrouver
une atmosphère comme celle-ci rebondira
forcément et on gardera cette expérience
au fond de notre cœur et également on
restera au contact avec nos clients et
notre PDG pas de repreneur en vue pour
le moment le tribunal de commerce
examinera la situation en début de
semaine prochaine l'établissement quant
à lui tire sa révérence ce samedi